I'm bangbang and I'm gonna answer some
questions about tattoos on Twitter
[Music]
pretty sure this is a dumb question but
say if you have a tattoo on your arm and
you somehow cut that arm what happens to
the tattoo do you just end up with new
skin in the middle of it yeah you get a
scar this is what that looks like
tell me again how these scars happened I
had piece of wire and an impact on and
the wire slipped out whipped around and
got me from my armpit mattress those
tattoos a few years old and some of what
I'm gonna do today is fix some of what
that metal wire did to him all these
scars throughout his tattoo for each
different grouping is something
different I'm gonna do so if I need to
really I find you to tattoo in a really
fine area I'll use a grouping of needles
and fewer needles depending on how large
I want that line to be now I'm just
trying to hide some of that scarring I'm
gonna keep some of it because it matches
the pattern of her dress but I kind of
like to work like a copy machine so I
like to finish it block by block and
just move along since my hands are
rested on the person we got to kind of
finish it and then we can put our hands
on that finished area and work above
that's kind of the way I learned you'll
always have a scar like no matter what
but we'll get the tone to match if it's
a deep cut you'll get a line right
through your tattoo if you get stitches
and they don't sew it together evenly it
can be crooked if you get a bad one I
would recommend asking a plastic surgeon
to to close it because I've seen them
misaligned tattoos and then there's
really no fix in it even a cat scratch
can remove pigment from your skin and
leave you with a little mark of fresh
skin I have seen some some very bad ones
people working in kitchens it cover the
knife the worst that it can be is if
it's if it heals back misaligned yeah
that's a tough one how hard is it to get
a tattoo removed asking for a friend
if you're getting a tattoo removed
there's two ways to do it sandpaper and
laser I recommend laser people do that
seen it on Instagram people removing
tattoos with sandpaper God Russians
see laser removal it works both of my
hands actually wear tattoos previously
that I had lasered and covered up so
yeah you can totally get laser done and
it works it works pretty well from a
beam a what's the best way to make a
word tattoo interesting that's the
question I don't want just words if
you're trying to make a text tattoo
really interesting try to make it unique
unless you want a common horizontal text
on ribs tattoo and then you know go for
it my favorite phrase I think I've ever
tattooed on someone was pocket queen of
blending howdy folks get simple words
and basic grammar all wrong tattooed on
their body does this mean the tattoo
artist fails too I'm not sure her
grammar in that tweets perfect there's a
reason we're tattooers and not english
teachers like yeah we're not the best
spellers we do a lot of spellcheck we do
a lot of grammar checking and people
still do get it wrong oftentimes it's
from a song lyric you know we know we
know it's wrong but it's the lyric so it
works and works for that person we talk
about it sometimes
remember I Tunes something on it on
someone once where we purposefully
changed grammar losing apostrophe so it
feels more linear we definitely talk
about it and we do our best but yeah
I've seen some pretty bad ones from Lea
does anyone know how much a person
should tip a tattoo artist tips are not
expected by tattoo artists so it's
really on you it's really cool someone
gives you a thoughtful tip speaking for
myself I'd like deeply appreciate the
people who get tattooed by me when they
get me something specific to me that's
more than just like money and a
handshake that's really special I think
that's cool sorry I didn't answer your
question I don't know 20% Oh from Haley
how do you draw a tattoo based on a song
help whenever we design tattoos we start
with subject matter so what's the song
about then it's like okay what's gonna
be the best visual interpretation of
that subject and then what is going to
work best on you and your body find your
subject matter find your great tattoo
artist to help you design it I feel like
I have tattooed let it be like a hundred
times
an amazing song and uh like a perfect
tattoo I might need to let it be tattoo
from robben tattoo artists are
incredible like how do you draw on a
squishy and perfect surface without an
eraser and consistently create good
pieces it's tough to draw around a
person's body we only get so many passes
on someone's skin before we scar them
you have to be very precise and direct
and what you do sometimes you have to
like give up you can take the skin as
far as you know you can take it and if
you didn't get it exactly where you want
to be you have to stop to answer your
question the way we make these tattoos
great and on a consistent basis is
preparation preparedness it kind of
lines you up for success a great tattoo
artist is very prepared for what he's
gonna do or what she's gonna do they
know what the tattoo is gonna be before
they even begin I use a traditional
tattoo machine the electromagnets turn
on and off and a spring that carries it
back and forth and the capacitor
regulates the energy and that
electricity moves through the power unit
and I control it from my foot switch
sound like some machine they are
essentially the guts of a doorbell
that's why I said this is a traditional
tattoo machine there are several
different kinds and you'll see some of
the artists here working with tattoo
machines that look much more like a pen
now the reason I really love working
with these kind of tattoo machines is
they're all handmade you have to be a
tattoo artist or recommended by tattoo
artist as an apprentice to be able to
buy one of these from one of the guys
who makes them now there's knockoffs and
you know you could buy a tattoo machine
on Amazon or like Walmart but you will
not get the same result they have to be
handmade by an expert tattoo artist a
lot of tattoo artists will not sell
tattoo machines online they will only
sell them in person to a person they
know they really don't want to get their
tattoo machines in the hands of someone
who can harm somebody you have five is
in here until I start tattooing that's
the difference between rotaries and
machine I love this sound from Adrienne
so like what's up with LeBrons tattoos
does he have any cool stories i tattooed
LeBron once and I have a cool story I
got a phone call one night at 8:00 p.m.
that LeBron wanted to get tattooed the
next day he was in Cleveland and I was
in New York so I fly there and I get to
LeBrons house I say hi I go downstairs
walk past his bowling alley into his
barber shop and I forget ink caps which
are pretty important they hold our ink
when we tattoo and the size of those
caps matters when I'm diluting inks I
needed ink caps so I started calling
tattoo shops and in the area and say hey
I'm in town to tattoo an athlete and I
totally forgot my end caps
my name is bang bang I'm a tattoo artist
I'm not some junkie making kitchen
tattoos I'm really in a bind can you
help me out people like hang up the
phone amazing jeez I was like I guess I
got a name drop hey tattoo and LeBron
really need ink caps can we be friends
please that nobody would listen so I
found a head shop that sold pipes and
tattoo equipment in Cleveland we drove I
picked up in caps go back we made a
really cool portrait of his daughter on
his back put him through a bunch of pain
his mom said you're the greatest at what
you do like my son is the greatest at
what he does and coming from the bronze
mom I was one of the best compliments I
ever got keeping up with Kelly in case
you wanted to know how a tattoo can
change over time this is the 10 year
difference I didn't realize how bad it
looks until now I saw what it looked
like when I first got it done how do you
even fix this when a tattoo is first
made that tattoo is as sharp as it'll
ever be at that moment over time your
white blood cells come and break this
pigment down and carry it away
in this case where you have a dense
kanji and the area in between each one
of these symbols of your skin this area
is quite small as the black settles into
your body and spreads those spaces of
skin start to become less visible for
your tattoo to fix it there's a couple
of things you can do you can cover it
with a much larger tattoo and you can
pull your eye away from this area or you
can get it
touched-up it looks to me since it's so
closed up and there is not as much skin
in between as there used to be that you
would need to put white around it so
that your eye can make a clear
separation between the black ink and
then that gray blurred edge and then a
little bit of skin in between and then
again it picks up that gray blurry edge
and then black inks let me show you how
that's done since this tattoo is quite
old this is about seven years ago we did
this I just want to add a little bit of
contrast to any areas that I think I've
aged and changed a bit
so I want to make sure his tattoo stays
as sharp as the day we did it and I can
do that with just a couple of darker
edges and a couple spots that will help
the I separate and put contrast to some
things that have aged I'm gonna work
around here around her hand a little bit
I'm just gonna create a little bit of
edge between where her hand is and this
cloth that she's holding whenever
there's not a defined edge next to
something I'm gonna try to make the edge
a little more defined this test who's
aged really well whenever I tattoo I'm
trying to think of how the tattoo will
age and so the contrast points are
really strong so there's really deep
darks and really light lights right next
to it it makes a really easy step for
the eye to see I'm trying to create the
thinnest little edge just to separate to
areas that are in highlight so I wanted
to separate enough for the eye to see it
but I don't want to put a big thick
black line in so although I could do
that with this that variable of depth
right now I'm trying to control the
depth of it as I'm moving my hand will
give me just a much lighter effect
imagine it hurts a lot less - right yeah
if you've ever seen it senses it's very
old it's very blurry working really
large or with high contrast over big
areas helps to avoid the image changing
as the tattoos gonna settle when you're
80 it's gonna look like
this is why when I tattoo I'm making
decisions based on what it's going to
look like in several years from John
fellow tattooed peeps how did you find
your tattoo artist there's no decent
website and Instagram search is useless
Instagram is pretty helpful I think
there's some cool like tattoo fan pages
just an assortment of different artists
works from around the world so you can
kind of find a style you like find that
artist and track them down information
travels really fast nowadays so you have
access to the entire planet like in your
pocket on your cell phone do some good
research and you'll find someone really
great probably not too far from you
there is a lot of amazing artists in the
world from Ameren arkad twitter who
designed bang Bang's
tattoos store on Grand Street in New
York I need to know
Jesse McGowan is a designer I've worked
with since I opened my first store a me
and Jesse kind of collaborate I know
what we need for tattooing Jesse really
knows what we need for the eye the core
value of the design of the stores
balance it's black and it's white on
purpose and there's no art hanging in
our stores because we're making it it's
built specifically for artists
experience and clients experience when I
design the store with Jesse we thought
about where people are gonna sit where
that wire is gonna come from where it's
gonna run to where's the power source
for it and we hit a lot of things we've
eliminated certain wires on like floor
lamps for example now they're
battery-powered
so we just lose one of those obstacles
tattooing is very stressful and being
tattooed is really stressful we wanted
to make an environment that's incredibly
welcoming and break that barrier down so
there's amenities for artists there's
places to relax there's big dinner table
and there's TV downstairs there's fish
it's my job as the owner of the store to
make people feel comfortable whether
they're making tattoos or receiving them
for tattoo artists we pour so much of
ourselves into our work and then it
walks out the door and we don't see it
anymore it's a little like sad it's kind
of a bummer that was tattoo support I'm
bangbang thanks for watching